et finalement avec toute cette drogue
dans le cycline les jeunes sont pas
spécialement en tirés par sa
ignant bonsoir vous resterez dans
l'histoire du cyclisme français comme un
des rares à avoir gagné deux fois le
tour de France en 83 et 84 mais vous
resterez encore plus comme celui qui l'a
perdu de 8 secondes à la dernière étape
en 89 voilà vous avez pas égalé le
palmarès de Louison Bobet vous racontez
tout ça dans un livre qui paraissait de
semaine et vous annoncer parallèlement
votre cancer Laurent oui pour faire le
buzz vous êtes champion
de circonstances le livre était terminé
et j'ai appris un petit mois après que
j'avais malheureusement cette maladie
si vous propose le pot belge pour guérir
ça vous dites NON quoique si ça se
trouve personne n'a jamais essayé
on reconnaît le cycliste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous étions jeunes et insouciants où
vous racontez votre carrière dans le
cyclisme amateur et professionnel
pendant les années 80-90 et vous
commencez votre bouquin par ce fameux
tour 89 que vous avez perdu à cause de 8
secondes et c'est très poignant quand
vous racontez ça vous vous dites c'est
les Champs-Élysées l'avenue du martyre
quoi c'est vraiment
ça vous flingue ce truc là quoi
effectivement c'est dur c'est très dur à
encaisser aujourd'hui je dirais même que
ça continue de me poursuivre j'en suis
pas complètement abattu à chaque fois
qu'on en parle mais on en parle tout le
temps les gens vous disent je vous
reconnais vous êtes celui qui a perdu le
tour de 8 secondes alors vous vous dites
NON je suis aussi celui qui en a gagné
deux en même temps oui ça c'est un peu
la mentalité française
pas forcément des défaites mais des
histoires en tout cas et doivent avoir
gagné deux je sais pas si tout le monde
s'en souvenait donc
tu vas faire ça bah oui c'est vrai et
c'est vrai qu'après quand vous faisiez
des courses après ce tour de 89 les gens
sur la route vous disaient quand ils
voyaient passer vas-y vas-y tu as encore
8 secondes de retard
mais en plus c'était pas toujours le cas
la grande révélation du bouquin c'est
que vous vous êtes dopé Laurent Laurent
Fignon dopé moi le monde c'est
écroulé comme j'ai vu ça qui aujourd'hui
pensait que le cyclisme n'avait pas eu
de page avant avant les 98 vous savez
quand vous regardez l'histoire du
cyclisme dès les frères Pélissier ils
avouent qu'ils prennent des produits
parce que c'est trop dur c'est c'est
inhumain donc ça a toujours été comme ça
la seule chose qu'on pourrait me
reprocher c'est de ne pas avoir senti
que c'était de la triche d'être d'avoir
été pris par mon métier par l'ambiance
du de cette époque là pire que vous en
fait c'était avant le PO hein c'était
les amphétamines et la cortisone les
amphétamines étaient contrôlés à tous
les à tous les à toutes les courses donc
c'était pas pour les courses c'était
pour les critérium un petit peu festifs
on s'amusait le soir avec ça puisqu'on
dormait pas donc on s'amusait la
cortisone ou effectivement mais par
exemple qu'aujourd'hui avec une
justification médicale on a le droit de
prendre la cortisone est-ce que c'était
vraiment du dopage finalement on peut se
poser la question et dans la politique
il y a du dopage aussi sûrement non
en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne
sorti du marque je peux pas dire MAPA un
soda qui d'énergisant je prends rien ah
ouais mais pas de café on parle beaucoup
de pages dans le cyclisme pour moi qui
ai fait un livre sur un footballeur je
me suis beaucoup intéressé au football
et je trouve scandaleux qu'on ne parle
pas du dopage dans le foot alors insu ou
pas ils sont dopés après mon enquête
voilà une vraie journaliste
a fait un livre sur William gallag je
dis pas qu'il est dopé d'ailleurs
du milieu et qui m'ont dit surtout ne
l'écrivez pas mais voilà et je peux vous
dire à tel match ceci et voilà donc
c'est quand même scandaleux de faire
autant sur le dopage dans le cyclisme
mais que fait-on du foot pourquoi parce
qu'il y a trop d'âge d'argent pourquoi
alors racontez aussi la cocaïne
beaucoup évidemment
mais c'est du passé je dis ça
oui possible on est entre repenti
finalement
vous parlez du Tour de Colombie en 84
vous racontez qu'il y avait des suiveurs
qui avaient des kilos de coq dans dans
le coffre de la voiture quand même je
vais mettre au vélo moi c'est fini je
pense c'est l'époque des
narcotrafiquants
et c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'à cette
époque là une info gratuitement aimé
beaucoup le vélo le vélo était très
supporté en Colombie par ces gens-là
Michel Drucker quand il fait Michel
quand il fait le Ventoux
avec Michel et je peux vous dire que non
ça fait pas cet effet là non non il
monte
ce qui est bizarre c'est finalement avec
toute cette drogue dans le cycline les
jeunes sont pas spécialement en tirés
par ça il y a pas de drogue
sérieusement quand vous commentez le
Tour de France pour France 2 comment
vous pouvez continuer à admirer ces
gens-là alors que vous savez qu'en fait
ils sont un peu aidés moi quand je
commande je suis plutôt du côté
technicien donc j'explique ce que je
vous voyais à l'antenne j'essaie de vous
dire pourquoi ça roule vite pourquoi ça
roule pas vite quelle tactique il peut y
avoir après effectivement de temps en
temps il y a des choses qui me semblent
un peu bizarre mais je peux pas non plus
prendre position définitive je ne sais
pas vraiment 10 ans qui est pas eu un
vainqueur du Tour autour duquel il est
pas eu des rumeurs des soupçons ou des
condamnations et ça je le dis encore une
fois en amoureux du Tour
c'est quand même très perturbant parce
que quand tu vois passer Armstrong qui
monte le bisque à 75 km à l'heure
une fois en haut
d'avoir suivi une étape contre la montre
du tour sur notre Fribourg et Mulhouse
et j'étais derrière l'Allemand on a
commencé
une riche et alors il a foncé pendant 60
km sans se relever sans respirer etc
comme une flèche j'arrive et puis il
était second il avait été plus vite
mais en fait ça empêche pas les gens de
regarder le Tour de France heureusement
non mais c'est bizarre quand même ils
savent que les mecs sont un peu aidés
quoi ça change rien de l'effort est
toujours le même si on va un peu plus
vite si on allait on a l'impression que
c'est un peu trafiqué l'effort est
toujours le même vous êtes tous monté
sur un vélo vous avez vu comment c'était
dur on est vite c'est rouler vite qui
est dur en vélo alors Christine le CSA a
qui est tellement soucieux qu'on fume
pas à l'écran qu'on boivent pas de
champagne à l'écran mais quand vous
voyez le Tour de France vous dites rien
le CSL
je vois le Tour de France
personnellement là je parle à titre
personnel je suis
quand je reviens de Roland-Garros
idem quand je regarde une course à la
voile idem et justement j'enquête pour
savoir pourquoi il y a autant de marques
qui apparaissent pas sur qui ils sont
tombés
voilà donc vous appréciez à sortir ce
livre qui je le dis vraiment passionnant
et là vous avez appris le 20 mars que
vous aviez le cancer quoi c'est un
cancer des voies digestives voilà c'est
tout ce que l'on sait donc pourrait
semblablement plutôt estomac pancréas ça
change pas grand chose finalement il
faut le battre voilà
ça serait mieux vous serez fixé quand là
dessus sur cette peut-être jamais il y a
un ou deux pour cent de cas où on ne le
retrouve jamais
j'apprends quelque chose ça empêche pas
de guérir oui oui bon vous souhaite de
toute façon les ganglions déjà diminué
le moitié mais à peu près c'est un petit
peu après deux séances
est-ce que vous pensez que ce cancer est
dû à tout ce que vous avez pris à
l'époque ou non non je crois absolument
pas je dis pas simplement ça comme ça à
la limite il vaudra peut-être mieux pour
les générations futures
et là je l'ai donc je peux pas faire
autrement mais je crois vraiment pas
vous avez décidé de vous battre vous
dites je vais faire tout ce qu'il faut
pour pas y passer c'est bien j'ai déjà
commencé bien sûr j'ai changé mon
alimentation bien sûr après mon mode de
vie vous dites j'ai pas peur de mourir
j'ai une belle vie je suis comme un an
ça va aujourd'hui c'est vrai quand on
m'a annoncé ça et forcément c'est la
première chose à laquelle on pense
puisque c'est une maladie mortelle et
puis je me suis dit mais ça me fait pas
peur alors est-ce que c'est parce que
justement j'ai une belle vie c'est vrai
que d'ailleurs le livre parle de tout ça
avant le dopage avant toutes ces choses
là
bon peut-être que c'est ça je sais pas
mais j'ai pas envie par contre j'ai
vraiment pas envie il a gagné le Tour de
France combien de fois après le cancer
cette fois
je vais réessayer c'est ça non
oui oui bien sûr il y a beaucoup plus de
guérison qu'on le croit de beaucoup de
mails de gens nous disant il dit à finir
de rester avec nous parce que on va pas
se retrouver avec Virenque comme on tend
le
tour sur France Télévision voilà donc ça
il y a beaucoup de gens
voilà faites-nous plaisir restez avec
nous en tous les cas vous avez l'air
d'avoir la pêche merci
[Musique]
courage courage
je crois toute la France est avec vous
là vraiment je crois que tout le monde
vous tout le monde vous soutient vous
supporte merci beaucoup de messages de
sympathie et ça m'a fait très plaisir je
peux pas répondre à tout le monde mais
je remercie tout le monde courage
camarade
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu